this is a video I should probably have
made a while ago but better late than
never I've been talking about AI safety
for quite a while now and in a very
public way on the computer file Channel
since about 2014 from the beginning a
lot of AI safety advocacy has had a
certain quality to it which to be honest
I'm sure I've contributed to a little
bit and it's true
that might be the appropriate response
to the problem but if you want to warn
people about something it matters how
you phrase things and how you frame
things ideally the argument would stand
on their own merits people should be
able to look at the facts and decide for
themselves and one of the things I'm
trying to do with this channel is to
give people the information they need to
form their own informed opinions about
this kind of thing but at the end of the
day most people don't have the time to
put in to get the required level of
understanding and they shouldn't have to
I mean it's not actually possible to
study everything in enough detail to
understand it there's just too much to
know so we have experts but this kind of
sucks because then how do you choose
your experts it turns clear objective
question questions about science and
facts into these messy ambiguous
questions about status and
respectability and a lot of the time
scientists don't want to lower
themselves to playing that kind of game
so they don't play at all or play
half-heartedly but uh this is one of
those games you can't win if you don't
play and we do need to win there are
problems with having to trust experts
but ultimately specialization is how we
manage to swap sucky problems like we
keep being eaten by Predators for really
cool problems like what if our
technology becomes too powerful and
solves our problems too effectively
that's a good problem to have yeah sorry
hin insects are one of the most
successful groups of animals on Earth so
a couple of years ago people had a go at
making AI safety more respectable with
this open letter which was often
reported something like Steven Hawking
Elon Musk and Bill Gates warn about
artificial intelligence usually with a
picture of the Terminator also
surprisingly often Steven
Hawkings why does this keep happening is
he secretly a team of clones anyway the
letter itself isn't very long and
basically just says AI is advancing very
rapidly and having more and more impact
so we need to be thinking about ways to
make sure that impact is beneficial it
says we need to do more research on this
and it links to a document that gives
more detail about what that research
might look like so the content of the
letter itself isn't much to talk about
but the core message I think is that
this stuff isn't just science fiction
and it's not just futurologists who are
talking about it real serious people are
concerned this was good for
respectability with the general public
because everyone's heard of these people
and knows them to be respectable smart
people but I've seen people who are
slightly more sophisticated noticing
that none of those people are AI
researchers Professor Hawking is a
physicist Bill Gates is a software
developer but Microsoft at the time he
was working there was never really an AI
company doesn't count and Elon Musk
though seriously overpowered is more of
a business person and an engineer so why
do these people know anything in
particular about a but there are
actually more than 8,000 signatures on
this
letter top of the list here is Stuart
Russell he's actually currently working
on AI safety and I plan to make some
videos about some of his work later if
you've never studied AI you may not know
who he is but uh he's a pretty big name
I'm not going to say he wrote the book
on artificial intelligence but
uh I I am going to imply it pretty
heavily and of course his co-author on
that book Peter norvi he's also on the
list what's he up to these days director
of research at Google the signatories of
this open letter are not AI
lightweights who else have we got Demis
hassabis and just about everyone a deep
mind uh Yan Lun head of AI at Facebook
Michael wridge head of the computer
science department at
Oxford uh I mean I'm skipping over big
people but uh yeah Tom Mitchell I know
him from a little book I used as a PhD
student you know this is an expert cuz
the name of his book is just the name of
the subject that's not a totally
reliable heuristic though anyway my
point in this video is just if you're
talking to people about AI safety it's
not cheating to say oh these high status
respectable people agree with me but if
you're going to do that pay attention to
who you're talking to if it's someone
who's heard of Russell or norvig they're
likely to find that much more convincing
than Elon Musk and Steven Hawking and
don't use me for this I am just a guy on
YouTube
[Music]
I just want to thank my amazing patreon
supporters uh and in particular Ichiro
DOI who skips the queue by sponsoring me
$20 a month I don't even have a $20 a
month reward level now I've got to make
one that's a good problem to have anyway
thank you so much you may have noticed
that the gap between this video and the
previous one is shorter than usual and
it's largely thanks to my patreon
supporters that I made ble to do that so
thanks again and I'll see you next time